la compagnie bo viennent aux frais 3
millions de comprimés de cure au keno
gouvernement merkel pour tenter de
sauver des patients atteints du coroner
virus quelques heures plus tôt en point
de presse le prise d'un trompe parler de
la chloroquine comme d'une panacée
kruger
tout récemment un centre de recherche
marseillais l'a testé sur 24 patients
gravement malades dont plusieurs ont
récupéré de lakovic 19 en chine et en
australie il fait aussi l'objet d'essais
cliniques sur des centaines de patients
et chez nous on n'est pas en arrière
d'apparat de la chloroquine et remporter
comme étant très efficace dans certaines
stations à peu près de donner à
n'importe qui
c'est pas un médicament spécifique comme
tel la nuance est importante
la chloroquine est un très vieux
médicaments anti-malaria découvert il ya
deux siècles on a observé récemment que
ce produit peut parfois réduire le
nombre de virus qui circule dans
l'organisme d'un patient est donc
favorisé sa guérison mais il n'a jamais
fait l'objet d'une grande étude clinique
et un intérêt qui est manifeste parce
que il y a eu des jeux des études en
laboratoire qui ont montré qu'il pouvait
y avoir un potentiel mais du côté
vraiment des études cliniques qui a pas
de démonstration franche est établi dans
la communauté scientifique le québec
permet que médecins utilisent ce produit
dans un contexte expérimental pour des
patients grande difficulté on le fait
déjà l'hôpital général juif de montréal
mais on suggère d'éviter de prescrire
largement ou d'en faire un usage courant
il ya des gens qui en ont même à la
maison parce que ils auront voyagé puis
on leur donnait sur un type de
prévention pour une infection de malaria
qui peuvent se dire maman de joie
l'utiliser puisse avoir assuré on
recommande pas non plus donc
selon les autorités américaines la santé
il faudrait au moins six mois avant
d'établir si la chloroquine représente
ou non une option thérapeutique de choix
dans la lutte contre le corps à 9,6
norma grondin radio canada montréal